georges fillioud le ministre de la
communication redit dans une interview
au journal du dimanche son hostilité à
la publicité sur les antennes des radios
libres
vous savez que le sénat a émis la
semaine dernière un avis différent sur
cette question georges fillioud restera
donc fidèle à sa position quand le
dossier des radios libres arrivera
devant l'assemblée nationale
pas de publicité dit il parce que d'une
part on ne pourrait pas la contrôler et
parce que d'autre part cela mettrait en
péril la presse écrite régionale
quant aux principaux intéressés c'est à
dire les radios libres elles mêmes elles
sont divisés sur cette question l'une
des trois familles des radios libres
celle qui justement est d'accord avec
jean georges fillioud sur cette question
la fédération nationale des radios
libres celle la tenue d'un congrès ce
week-end plus de 100 radios libres à
paris et dans la région parisienne près
de 500 au total en france devant cette
prolifération d'antennes georges fille
lui annonce ce matin son refus de la
publicité lors de son congrès ce
week-end la fédération nationale des
radios libres qui ont représente une
centaine rappelle ses visées non
lucrative elle demande à ses adhérents
de s'autofinancer localement par
l'organisation de concerts ou par des
cartes d'auditeurs en somme un refus
plutôt systématique des contrôles
quelle qu'en soit l'origine jeu et nous
revendiquons nous à notre titre
le droit d'aimer font sens aux
contraintes financières ou sans
contraintes politiques actuellement le
débat sur les radios libres se polarise
sur le problème de la publicité êtes
vous pour ou contre la publicité c'est
vrai mais nous pensons que le poids ne
s'oppose pas de cette manière là le
premier a eu un glissement man dans la
manière de poser le problème on est
partis au départ de quelle était la
vocation du rail au local et à cette
question nous répondions les radios
locales doivent être des véritable
support des nouvelles pratiques
radiophonique d'une nouvelle espèce de
promotion culturelle des changes dans
les villes et on est arrivés
progressivement une question centré sur
la publicité sur la publicité notre
fédération est clair et net eur
nous pensons
nous sommes contre la publicité car nous
ne voulons pas ouvrir dans ce pays une
brèche la commercialisation des ondes
en fait ces radios lips heurte un double
obstacle d'une part la répartition des
fréquences d'antenne d'autre part les
recettes publicitaires
ainsi la question des fréquences pose le
problème des rapports avec les pouvoirs
publics qui est bien évident que nous
définissions du corps comme le radio
elles dépendent dans le fait qu'en
fonction de cela nous attachons une
importance trop grande sur la forme de
régionalisation le tout vers des
décisions qui va être qui va être donnée
en particulier pour l'attribution de
bricoles est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
inquiet du projet de développement des
radios locales de france inter ou de fr3
lyon que nous faisons de ce problème
une thèse de pour la les promesses de
communication sociale que l'on parle le
gouvernement c'est à dire que le ces
radios du service du secteur public
à terme le risque bien sûr d'amusant
d'un particulier rural de concurrencer
les radios libres qui vont se développer
le second enjeu celui de la publicité en
appelle directement à la survie même de
ces radios sans grands moyens financiers
ni professionnels venus c'est très sain
parce qu'on s'aperçoit d'une chose c'est
que depuis qu'il ya eu donc cette
discussion au sénat avec un certain
nombre d'amendements autorisant la
publicité radio tomate est à peu près
inaudible surtout paris voit simple
raison que je radios commerciales qui se
sont mis très très proche de nous avec
des gigantesques émetteurs pratiquement
dit fier watts donc radio tomates
n'existe plus bon alors là dessus c'est
pas du tout un problème idéologique tour
contre la publicité tel qu'on a pu
l'imposer
c'est simplement que dans les faits qui
est un antagoniste complètement
irréductible entre d'un côté des radios
commerciales et d'un autre côté des
radios libres